boys fellas welcome back to the pot we
all know that reading is a typically
feminine hobby you'll never be a real
man unless you read these five
Essentials now I'm gonna put my hair
into a bun even though I could have done
that before the camera turned to book
number one The Art of War even though
this book is about like centuries-old
military strategies there's still a lot
of relevance to being a man fellas is it
gay to read the next book meditations by
Marcus oh oh really this guy has a crazy
ass break book number three
I'm blinking maybe like the old man in
the sea but that's fiction and I don't
think men should read read Fiction it's
a waste of time personally I believe
cancel me on Twitter if you want there's
two more there are they're in my head
they're in my little Noggin I can I'm
just trying honestly my memory has been
really bad ever since I started taking
those supplements oh I remember
it's Lucy ellman's spellbinding
Masterpiece and the 2019 Booker Prize
winner this epic Tome is a beautiful
meditation on love and loss
and the fifth book is Greenacres